hello and welcome to guys trailer
commentary for Star Wars doubles the
last Jedi I'm Spencer J comfort that's
Joestar that's Dan Morrill I'm glad
someone's finally gonna talk about this
movie
finally flicks on the Internet three
white nerds talking star wars the last
gen what the world has been missing oh
god man I just can't think of another
outlet that has just guys like this
talking about franchises like Star Wars
it's crazy
we've got appropriate logos for other
films we enjoy on our t-shirts solutely
pretty cool yeah very very cool very
very cool that said we did make an
honest trailer for this movie a divisive
film I was shocked at how divisive it
was I walked out thinking I enjoyed that
film yeah and found out why I was a
heretic on the Internet you can check
the tape when I reviewed this movie
after I saw it I predicted this would be
the most divisive Star Wars movie of all
time because I myself was divided and
I'm still divided you were split apart
like kylo Ren ever killing his father
let apart I'm torn I was torn asunder by
this movie there are parts that I love
there are parts that I didn't like and I
would I think it's safe to say that I
was the least enthusiastic of the three
of us sure safe to say now here's the
thing I came of age in the prequel era
where Star Wars was terrible yes and
people who deny that and I was primed
prequel like an age but god damn did I
know that those movies sucked when I saw
these movies despite any of their flaws
are so much better than what we've
gotten in the past that I don't
understand how you could be upset by
them after a full decade of boring crap
well I don't think anyone was comparing
it to the prequels I certainly wasn't I
was i I just think that it had some
tonal inconsistencies some storytelling
inconsistencies I'm not judging the
rightness or wrongness of the direction
I understand the direction that they
took this movie I think that there were
some inconsistencies
of how the story was being told that
showed but now in the movie itself were
compared to for swig compared to this
the overall arc of the story the setup
to the story and like within that
contained in the movie or are you
comparing it it is part 2 of 3 so yes I
am PI I'm judging it apart based on the
story that was begun in the previous
movie that they are continuing in this
movie I thought that there were some
choices that were made in this movie
that just rang very hollow compared to
how they had been telling the story
previously and it stuck out to me that
this was not in any way planned or meant
to be how it is to get to me in a way
that wasn't unplanned it was like whoa
we kind of shipped me out of my boredom
but like my oh this is Joseph Campbell
it's the monomyth - yeah she's the farm
girl who actually turns out to be the
princess and like it was like oh wow I
did not see this coming
so whether it was planned or not we'll
see how it's resolved in part 3 well it
wasn't but pretty heavily stated that
Rian Johnson was like yeah and then just
kind of did his own thing so he was I'm
not I'm unclear in the timeline because
at what point was JJ writing part 3
never until I don't like to tell
whatever all got yeah but I know that
like Rian Johnson took a look at sort of
JJ's outline wanted to do his own thing
and then went back with the lucas story
group and sort of put together his last
Jedi yeah so the weird idea that he like
went wrote was somehow able to go rogue
against the company with like murder
satellites in the air if you like screw
with their franchises is a little weird
to me like that narrative from fate like
you can't think Disney is an
uncompromising evil monolith and then
also think that the guy that made brick
was somehow able to circumvent their
system like the logic there doesn't
balance to me but you know for better or
worse this is the film that Lucasfilm
was like yep this this checks out
because for whatever is the plan did
miss or the unplanted miss things are
made upwards and I'm using those more
now
you're writing a part two of three you
gotta know that these are setups to
conclusions that will come in the next
movie or mr. X two things that will
happen in the next movie he wasn't like
this is it this is self-contained
nothing else happened before nothing
else will happen after it this just
seemed very much like the Star Wars that
Rian Johnson wanted to make which I am
NOT faulting Disney for giving him the
latitude to do that my my point and why
I think I stand a little bit of part was
I was not quite in the camp of like oh
my god this is startlingly original and
it's reinvigorated my blood for this
franchise because it's gone away that it
would never go I was kind of more in the
middle of just like okay I like some of
what they did with this and there's
other parts of it that to me were a
little just completely dissimilar and
not at all in tone or in line with what
was set up and when everything that's
been set up as a misdirect then that
again to me is just like alright well
maybe one or two things but when
everything in this movie is like the
opposite then that is a bit jarring to
me and I was one of those ones it was
just like I think he might have gone a
little too far
I think maybe word response to this
movie yeah it's just like again this
would have this would have been this is
the opportunity to have a really
interesting and deep discussion about
the Star Wars franchise that most of the
internet completely discarded in favor
of going into the fifth month it's not
it's actually provoking a more nuanced
discussion of the franchise than I'd
seen in the past because I think they've
watched the movie once and everybody has
now become a self-appointed expert on
story development and character action
it's just different from just yelling
about plot holes or nitpicks and stuff
like that so people are talking about
the roots of stories and setups and
payoffs and like I'm actually kind of
impressed for whatever the disagreements
that the the discourse has stayed on the
level of I guess craft and like oh where
are you reading yeah everyone's like the
character arcs the plot payoffs and
stuff like that people usually don't
talk about
seeker you're going to like this
lucasfilm's smoking because that's not
the discussion that means of course
there's your you know too many ladies
told guys what to do there's stuff in
there but yeah I think for the most part
that people have become self-appointed
screenwriters of this movie which is a
better way to tackle it than to just be
like I think there's a challenge to in
um I think with this whole new trilogy
no matter how it pans out in comparing
them or ranking them with like the
original trilogy because I've now I I
can't tell you how many times I've seen
the original trilogy movies I probably
think about them once a day you know and
it's like it's it's it I won't say
disingenuous that's too negative a word
I will say near insurmountable to like
walk out of the last Jedi for the first
time and like rank it with give it
context with these movies that you've
lived with your entire life it is is
challenging so rank it this is the
definitive rank of where this like you
just saw it five minutes yeah lettuce
and let it sit like I had to come review
the thing the day after I saw it and I
still didn't know it I thought yeah like
especially this one this thing of just
like you know I've got to be the first
to rank this and here's the definitive
rank and I will fight to the death for
this rank like a second what is it let
it marinate let it Return of the Jedi
came out today I would be like what is
this but I I've had 36 years to like
make myself at peace with a walks and
wicket and yum yum job and you know and
so I like it I love Return of the Jedi
for all of its the faults and maybe
someday in 36 years people be like you
know what that hold oh I get it I don't
know yeah
well guys should we get to the time code
that everyone's gonna say skip to in the
comment section for the start of welcome
to the
of you that said skip to this timecode
let's watch the on the charge it's good
to see you we had a good discussion you
should check it out if it's this no
what's it what's it ranked what's the
sport and stick around for deleted
scenes I've got to say that in a
polarized world the next installment of
the franchise all about balance and
non-attachment will be worshiped hated
and obsessed over until it's not even
fun to talk about anymore this is not
going to go the way you think man we
know Star Wars fans by now star wars the
last Jedi forget the love letter to the
originals that was the force awakens
because episode 8 subverts everything
you've come to expect making it the
worst one ever
oh who invited the original honest
trailer voice back are you really gonna
do the old ones or better / new ones are
better thing we did with the force
awakens the only way to talk about Star
Wars now is in absolutes
so yes kind of city of you but fine
pause so Ganon of the original voice of
honest trailers well not the first but
the first consistent voice of honest
yeah isn't the first one like an actor
so there was like three or four yeah
three or four different ones he's on the
west-world
right yeah yeah gross lab tech girl who
like does stuff for the bodies the it
was tough to know how to tackle this one
because obviously there's opinions and
we did the cop-out thing by just doing
both sides good for us yeah but isn't
that the the most honest way to address
this movie is to talk about how it's
honest trailers not pick aside trailers
you know when we have a movie like this
where the story is the argument then
that's the angle we probably should take
if we're gonna do the honest version
because the honest take on this movie is
nobody can agree I feel like the honest
trailer is never for a movie like this
is never what most people want it to be
because I see comments that are just
like it was my favorite Star Wars movie
I can't wait to see the honest trailer
like come through on the side of you
know me and then people who
like I can't wait to you guys period
garbage your Park like it tore apart my
life it's like it's never gonna be that
yeah so I think the most honest take is
there's two sets this story you know
balance we brought balance to the force
yeah we attempted to yeah but yeah
Gannon again it's great
we got work began in iPhone or my first
time fight via Skype or something like
that and he's a he doesn't look how he
thought he would they never do the voice
actors no but got a great voice and a
good to work with you he makes me laugh
man every any time he says a word he's
hilarious yeah I was kind of like
because I was working on the following
on his trailer so I was on headphones
but I'd hear have just weird random
sentences that again and on like takes
and stuff yeah it's cracked I love he's
got a he's has a very particular timbre
and tone to his voice I think is very
funny in a different way that job is
very funny yeah I think they complement
each other really well very nicely so
we're gonna be doing this for every
honest trailer you know your home making
last Jedi a refreshing update to a
predictable formula that spits in the
face of everything you once loved whiner
traitor
me the new class of heroes coming into
their own like Ray who actor being
called by Luke's lightsaber is called by
the Jedi Tech all called by a big wet
hole and called by her greatest frenemy
that's Joseph Campbell man yet still
gets zero answers to any of her
questions
I thought HUD finances him I was right
Poe who grows from a hotshot sexy pilot
to a treasonous failure with more blood
on his hands than the empire first order
same difference and fed who went from a
deserter running away from the war to a
deserter running away from the war with
the help of newcomer Rose he'll learn to
put the greater good above himself
thanks to a pointless side quest to
casino royale' because how dare they
spend 15 minutes connecting the action
to a larger thing the larger theme being
is it possible to miss pod racing I
didn't think so
but here we are
canta bites I didn't mind it I mean you
need the cantina in force awakens' you
had maz kanata's place you need this
that hive of scum and villainy in in
Star Wars movies this was actually more
in tone with Star Wars films of the past
to me than anything else yes you could
cut it yes this is the longest Star Wars
movie made but I did I also thought I
was interesting that they saved the
horses and not the slave children but
aside from that from that leads them but
also what are they gonna take those kids
back to the slowly running out of gas
ship and it has like snoke's b-1 bomber
right behind it like hey kid you say we
put them on the wrong transport yeah my
only complaint with Kanto blight is my
complaint with the new trilogy is that
well I really enjoy seeing all of the
new aliens and all the new practical
costumes and stuff like that you've lost
almost every like Star Wars alien and
stuff that like feel Star Wars to me
you're like there's no Twilight running
around in the background or Akbar guys
Mon Mon Cala Mars oh there's the
background
I'm sure there's novels written about
them already as we speak oh there are
there are but just like where did every
species go from Clone Wars in the
prequels and the original trilogy and
Star Wars rebels and like girls on oh
yeah it's a big galaxy but I will say
this the can't abide sequence isn't that
bad but it would have been a lot better
and made a lot more sense if Finn died
at the end because to me a whole point
of this is like Finn's its his part of
his journey and his arc and Rose is
helping him realize that like oh there's
like a bigger world out there and this
is like I
there's people suffering and it's not
just about me getting away from it all
which would have made sense for him to
sacrifice himself yes for a greater
cause at the end that's a kind of cop
down yeah that's where I the one place
where the movie did not subvert
expectation that I was disappointed that
it did not subvert it was like okay now
this is interesting he doesn't know I do
think that this this seemed to be
setting up Finn's heroic sacrifice at
the end yeah
so now it just seems like a kind of
vestigial little organ you consiste ik
there was a lot of night what felt like
nihilism in this movie and that was like
to me well I don't know I yeah I I saw
his Ark more about learning that there
is not an all time good side and an
old-time bad side and that the braver
sacrifices sort of staying the course
and focusing on protecting and saving
the the things you love and that one
grand gesture is it necessarily gonna be
what does that but that feeds again into
the nihilism of it all which is just
like I think that's what again I'm not
saying it's a bad message but it is so
out of whack with what anything that's
come before it is this thing of just
like it's a sidequest it doesn't matter
they failed anyway there are no good
guys that are no bad guys everybody's
ever in the middle of it and you only
really need to carry about the ones that
are with you you know their inner Jedi
there are no set the bad guys suck the
good guys everybody sucks
yeah that's an idea that DJ gives to
Finn that's not necessarily what the
[ __ ] did I do that the movie the movie
is also promoting very heavily this Luke
Skywalker's like the Jedi's legacy is
failure just show me the Wow shows that
show me the line yeah but again it's
this thing of just like it's ever
everything that was everything
everything was like this person sucks
that person you thought was good they're
not that good that person you thought
was bad maybe they're not so bad this
person sucks the Jedi's were failures
it's time to get rid of them that was
everything but this long saying what we
say about the Jedi like in all of our
honest trailers and every screen junkies
right now the movies are saying and and
that but but but to me that was but but
that's the whole but that was everything
in this movie everything in this movie
there's like everything you know sucks
and you need to get rid of all of it and
like I'm not saying I get it when people
say you don't get the last Jedi I get it
but I also get why there's some people
that were maybe a little upset that the
movie franchise that they love took an
official stances like by the way the
Jedi they're [ __ ] and you need to get
rid of them and they suck I like I say
it all wrong I'm saying that's why
people are upset they're not but it
because it was coming from Lucas Luke
Skywalker it seems to be endorsing them
mm-hmm
and he himself realized
that like he's been kind of on the wrong
track and then he sees ray and Kyle of
facetiming which freaks him out right
you know gets the force back up in them
I mean to me this was the this whole
movie it's the game of Thrones if
ocation of Star Wars where it's like you
have your Tolkien fantasy and then you
have Game of Thrones where it's like
Knights are [ __ ] kings and queens are
just a crapshoot of good or evil and
those drinks and who knows then we're
all drinks and she knows things and
we're all just kind of pawns in this and
I like that I think that that's a really
cool thing that's kind of truer to the
Spirit of Star Wars to me then we need
to worship these genetically pure race
of Skywalker's who have been passed down
from generation revolves around then
we're always happy to be a part of that
story else narrative that everybody who
doesn't agree with people that don't
like this movie says like oh I'm sorry
you only like whatever they spoon-fed
you in the past you say that's why I
like it but it's but that's the argument
that's used against people that have
problems with this movie is like I'm
sorry that you can't handle anything
different from what it's like that's not
what anyone else is saying I'm just
saying it's a little bit jarring for a
Star Wars movie to come along and just
say everything sucks and your heroes
aren't heroes and you you know the past
needs to go away everything you cared
about doesn't matter everything you
wanted an answer to is meaningless and
you know forget everything that came
before it cuz because none of it is
consequential anymore that's jarring but
I think that's what I think was a hero
in the end he just wasn't the hero that
like people were expecting which the
movie set up it's like do you just want
me to like walk up to a line of like a
hundred a dance with like a one
lightsaber like really big thing which
he called a laser sword researcher some
fans really got to Luke Skywalker I
think he he eclipses all that and become
something even better by finding a new
way which which would fit sort of the
you know the the Jedi Code and stuff
like that which is all about balance and
non-aggression he found he found that
actual sort of balance that he was going
for and sort of did something heroic was
it like a visceral like was it a scene
from the raid
- no but I think ultimately he did
something sort of heroic that mattered
and when you strip away the legends and
the Empire and the Jedi and the Sith and
all this things we we've we've defied
what are you left with
he left with regular-ass people looking
out for each other and I think that that
was with like worried about like the
three of us regular as dudes
manok with the with the kids of the
stable and the
dying embers of the resistance and the
way that people were told not to be
heroes in the traditional way that the
heroic thing is to just look out for
each other and not be holding ourselves
up to these insane crazy legendary
standards otherwise turned into kylo Ren
I'm just saying I hate that people can't
understand or seemingly don't want to
understand why people are so upset about
this movie because people in general
can't even seem to understand the other
side and I'm saying like it gets
frustrating to not be able to have the
discourse because I don't think either
side is right or wrong but you can't
even seem to have the discourse anymore
which is very yes everything is either
the best thing ever the worst thing I've
done
thanks mr. Sunday movies for that the
best review system ever and yeah they
take each thing for what it is let's get
to the second time code that they will
then stamp to get and it begins again
now yeah
but forget about the butthurt fanboys
who were just mad the movie isn't closer
to the one they wrote in their heads
hey because they're still all the old
favorites like Leia a battle-hardened
general trying to keep the spark of hope
and she's in a coma
Chewbacca who gets nothing to do and
Luke Skywalker who after sad old Han and
sad old Leia really drives home how your
heroes are all sad and old now he's
turned his back on the franchise after
watching the prequels legacy of the Jedi
his failure and not even reruns of a new
hope can change his mind that she moved
because what Star Wars fans really
needed was to see their Idol throw his
lightsaber away like it was some kind of
joke and Star Wars is not a joke to me
you have anything to talk to you about
Rian Johnson ruined my childhood like
you ruined the laws of space battle
there are no laws to space battle there
should be a lightsaber throw moment oh
yeah that told me that anything was
possible from here on out but I will say
this the people blaming Rian Johnson who
put Luke on that island
JJ palooka on that Island who had Luke
sit out for the force awakens while all
his friends JJ or JJ so you know you can
be upset wasn't you but I this to you
and I'm sure I'll actually get real
attempts back how would you explain Luke
sitting out for all the force awakens
he'd just been doing hella push that was
the situation that Brian Johnson had
been handed and I think be really to me
the only plausible one is like he turned
his back on the conflict so but I think
but I think that gesture throw the
lightsaber again is is that that single
moment encapsulates I think the debate
around this movie which is that the
force awakens ended with this very kind
of mythic moment a very striking image
of Rey on the rock handing the
lightsaber to Luke and the camera it's
the last shot of the movie I mean that
is just like a potential to be like just
a very iconic moment of like these two
characters meeting and like that is a
very that gestures like this is very
striking symbolism and then to come into
this movie and have that hat I think
that is the cadet is the key which is
like there's one side that would say
like no is it that great that the former
movie sets up this amazing moment and
then it turns out to be nothing like
that's so refreshing that you know it
doesn't matter but the other side and I
and I kind of if you can't tell I
contend a little bit more toward that
side is that is such an amazing Cinna
maduk moment and then to come back in
the next movie and defuse it again I'm
not saying that's the right of the wrong
choice I'm saying by a storytelling
standpoint you've taken what was the
kind of emotional climax of the last
movie and literally said doesn't matter
and it's just it's jarring it'll be
charging in his defense he was teaching
ray the way that he was taught which was
by Yoda which was first appeared to be a
crotchety old swamp creature who just
like seems like an idiot and then slowly
revealed it you're a Jedi Master it's in
the novelization excuse me it's actually
interesting I think it's a story but
they should have actually included maybe
had just started a few beats before she
arrives he's actually literally head
started that morning trying to burn down
that tree again it's just not very
flammable and just well no he could
never do it like it's one of those
things he always tries to do it and you
know he tries to do it then he has like
a Philip Seymour Hoffman in Boogie
Nights and moment brews like just a
stupid idiot like can't get it done so
that's why he's up there moping and then
all the sudden this lady shows up with
this lightsaber and he kind of like more
Jedi souvenirs which I don't know could
have given that some more context and it
wouldn't have been as jarring but so
would have started with him trying to
burn
yeah Jedi Temple down that would have
been less if you would if you I will not
there's no reality where JJ shot that
the way he did at the end of episode
seven for the next movie to immediately
strip it of all of its meaning and
that's what I mean when I say it's it's
obvious that these were two stories that
would not intended to be linked or in
the sense yeah well JJ didn't know what
he was going to do something up when you
set something up one way and then the
other way you completely start a new
tone and everything it wasn't meant to
be lights giant I think it was I think
Jay well not obvious I think JJ wrote
Ryan into a corner where like if because
playthrough the counterfactual this
where where
rheya hands Luke the lights here he goes
oh man I haven't seen this in a while
where are they at let's get him boys
like there's argument with the
ridiculous argument the other side and
saying that's the only I'm exaggerating
but theoretically he would have to he if
he saw that and accepted the call and
was like I'm back baby like then why was
he on the island in the first place I'm
not ever I'm saying that there's wait
there's a way to do it where you're not
just completely pulling the rug out from
it and that's what this movie seemed to
be doing at every turn was like not only
is it taking the franchise in the new
direction and I'm fine with that it was
just like get out of my way pull the rug
out slap in the face
push out of the way doesn't give them
add that doesn't give a [ __ ] who cares
and it's like that's what it was and it
just seemed like you know ryan johnson
was going into JJ Abrams china shop and
just kicking over all the shelves and it
just felt strange weird to me JJ Abrams
china shop has no China in it it's just
empty boxes empty plugs inside another
empty box they he doesn't have answers
and Ranchos is like alright there aren't
any answers here there's nothing in this
chance that's satisfying to ask a
question and the answer is there is no
answer that's just JJ yeah anyways let's
give God whatever you guys might attack
hold up Luke isn't the only Skywalker
who has issues with the franchise kylo
Ren is back and he's demanding a full
reboot but the past time killed it if
you have to when he doesn't look like
he's about to cry which is always
it's got a very your fanboy yeah I still
might wonder karabasan and his shirt you
distracted me on purpose
too late moving on get ready for truly
unexpected answers to the puzzles of
episode 7 that can only be answered by
asking what are the most dissapointing
answers to the puzzles of episode 7 like
who are raised parents nobody who is
Snoke some dead guy
and how did Maz Kanata get Luke's
lightsaber it doesn't matter and you're
stupid for asking that after all the
hours of speculation and analysis was
genuinely a celebrating whoa how do we
keep from a certain point of viewing
each other yeah we're both pretty big
Star Wars nerds huh so gear up for the
most divisive Star Wars film ever made
we're Rian Johnson either doesn't
understand the lore or he made the first
Star Wars movie that lives up to the
values it preaches instead of endorsing
Royal bloodlines and reckless aggression
okay enough division let's say our
favorite things about it on the count of
three one two three four wait really
yeah how long yeah okay we're know for
years least favorite wonder when I get
now can code down a peg but come on
they're taking shuttles to a fort why
make everyone think they're gonna die
again argue that though I'm sure people
will should we do this again for solo
yeah I'm not gonna see that crash rubble
is troubled stories after Star Wars fan
base salt blu-ray Internet Luke teat
milker Carrie Poppins Finn the human
I've been kissed by a rose our brain Chi
so serious
Snoke give me the car key keys your
classic usual suspects a short round pew
says we in adores sucks to be you
really mr. redemption for Star Wars kid
that would have been me if I'd has to
see until the next one comes out maybe
maybe it is time for my fandom to end
did you hear JJ finished the script
prepa sewed nine my fandom is back
temporarily well just to reward the
people who've stuck around this longer
end and deleted scenes our final
thoughts on the old franchise and
whatever yep so why make everyone think
they're gonna die I can't argue with
that
though I'm sure people will man I'm glad
the internet didn't exist when Empire
came out and a failing that over to
School of Rock Jay dude abides Luke
Perry old man Lucan nobody puts Carey in
a corner nothing but respect for my
princess City she's a cific thin forget
arose its canto bite baby driver that's
no moon Goldmember do some shrivel up
testicle dude irrelevant and they killed
phasma you bastards
you should really hold your judgement on
all the mysteries this is only part two
of three you know dude you have got to
see JJ Abrams TED talk our stories but
mystery boxes look like Star Wars who's
that we don't know mystery box do the
house alone Kenobi mystery box
withholding information you know doing
that intentionally is much more engaging
to Lightspeed
that's impossible actually if you recall
the archives in rogue one as well as
obi-wan tracking Jango Fett in Episode
two and the ghost being tracked in Star
Wars rebels I'll track their Lightspeed
with a beacon beacon was tracking is the
new tak sorry I thought you guys were
fans you gotta admit actually I didn't
resort to another Death Star trench run
no they just made it smaller and worse
mature eyes that star tech yeah I'll say
this in conclusion and you
also have your final thoughts as well
they're enough even if you don't want or
don't like the what they did in this
movie in particular it's got to be
exciting that this movie exists in a
world where we get star wars movies
twice a year now or every year now every
every year at least yeah it would appear
because we're going to get star wars
every year yes we need to at least have
the possibility of surprise and defiance
of our expectations even if it goes too
far and upsets people the fact that they
can make a Star Wars movie that risks
upsetting people has to give you some
spark of hope whereas if we were looking
at if if this was like force awakens
just kind of a retread of empire oh boy
get into one of those every single year
till long after we're dead would be
tough and this has reinvigorated my
interest of the franchise and I will at
least walk into them not knowing exactly
what's about to happen okay so that's my
piece yep you don't have any other piece
dad yeah you know Alyssa I think it's an
okay movie I would still say it's good
it's a good movie I I don't think that
episode 9 is going to feel anything like
this movie I think we're gonna have a JJ
Abrams 7 and then this kind of weird
jazz riff on Star Wars as 8 and then I
think we're gonna go back to JJ Abrams 9
so III sense that this movie is going to
be kind of flagged as a intriguing
curiosity in the franchise particularly
in these 3 movies but who knows there's
no there's a whole other one he's got a
whole other so there's a whole other
thing left and now he's got his own
desserts forth whatever first trilogy
whatever they're gonna call it I don't
know to do 12 yeah but III will be very
intrigued and it's like it's like he and
JJ we're having and he didn't know JT
was gonna do 9 it's like they're having
a competition about who could paint each
other into more of a corner because now
ryan johnson this painted JJ into an
even weirder worst corner where
everything that was sort of the threads
have all been cut from episode 7 so I
was kidding she's a princess yes we'll
see what happened
but yeah I don't know I think there's
room for new watson discussion
unfortunately when I hope we
demonstrated barrier today you idiot
you [ __ ] ah you don't like it as much
as me you're wrong ah reasons sir
anyway so haired lady this is fun to
write as fun to talk about still for me
next week's just kind of a fun one yeah
have a good time it's pretty wild
yeah well you know where you are yeah
yeah it's a they've got fun and games
there yeah yeah so I hope you'll join us
next week for this silly show we call
honest trailer commentaries and we'll
see you then
[Music]
you